well mike
i'm sick of you globetarts i'm
announcing it
i mean now a flat earther want to see
what changed my mind
the money you're saying to make delano
want to beat the mate tomato with the
scientists say we got
here from the big bang scientists y'all
can't suck on my big thing y'all say
gravity is this
[ __ ] if it's heavy it's gonna fall
just like dropping the bricks
scientists say we gotta hear from the
big bang but scientists y'all can't suck
on my big thing y'all say gravity is
this
[ __ ] if it's heavy it's gonna
yes they're using him up not only hit
him up but like
everybody every amateur rapper
just steals tupac's whole vibe
right like they always go like anybody
who just starts out and rap they always
rip off poc
just like dropping the brits
[Music]
[Laughter]
what if i have an infinity pool
the globalists lose
[Music]
you know what's funny with the flat
earthers
and i'm sure you've noticed this too
it really appeals to a certain group of
people like
even bas remember westbrook like even
basketball players like
it it's i don't know what it is about
flat earth like you know because
different conspiracies appeal to
different people obviously but the flat
earth one really does appeal to like
small brains yeah and when you touch
fire
don't that [ __ ] all the cops when you
see fox davey croco i got your docs
oh [ __ ] we love you shout out to baby
croco
now you're about to feel the wrath of a
very feminine menace
[Music]
i'm gonna let my little homie coddington
bear run on you [ __ ]
[ __ ] made mark ass [ __ ] glove
ass mother
get out the way yo get out the way yo
davey just got doxxed
is it dude okay that's very funny by the
way we could all agree
boyd is that song immediately dropping
quality when that guy
comes on holy [ __ ] oh man
[Laughter]
[Music]
the government and y'all
[Music]
the sun's not three million miles away
because he sees that [ __ ] every day
but it's um
okay so the sun
is really really big
and it's made of a bunch of uh fiery
gases
so we can see it i think you can [ __ ]
club tart
it's inside the [ __ ] firmament the
way it's in the bible you hate me
i don't give a [ __ ] you my rival
rainbow's proof it's a dole
[ __ ] sun dogs pool with saddam [ __ ]
the sun in the moon
bits in this water a [ __ ]
guys my dad is gay they took away my
paypal so i can't get paid
owen has a line on the side owen's one
of the shitty thug life guys on the
track he's like god get paid
the moon's a hologram it's all a lie
it's the van allen belt if you go
through it you'll die
ah and also the earth is flat and domed
and when you feel the moon beams they're
really cold
oh no everyone's on this track oh no
all the flat earthers are on it all the
flat earth and that football coach guy
is on there but he can't rap so he just
does like the intro
hey y'all i just won't tell you that uh
earth is flat and uh reed diary
like jesus i got everybody it's a
star-studded event
oh man scientists say we gotta hear from
the big bang besides y'all can't suck on
my big thing y'all say gravity is this
[ __ ]
you know what it is i don't think it's a
big thing you actually look like one of
those rare black guys that has a really
below average penis
which is like that's like the worst
thing to be in like a blackout or small
penis
gosh i always tell people that it's
but if you were a quarter of one you'd
say that too
washington i don't know what to do i
beat up my
dog and my wife won't talk to me too
that's right shout out to my
death row records the vfm the dread
all my in the esau all the west side
shout out to shout out to uh what's his
name [ __ ]
the guy from barcelona shout out to
farley
shout out to his old ass wife yo man all
your my foe makes all your [ __ ]
don't grow
[ __ ] joe rogan and his whole
[ __ ] crew and if you're down
with death squad
you'll [ __ ] you too brian redband
[ __ ] you too tony hinchcliffe [ __ ] you
too
brandon chubb [ __ ] you too you ever hear
the version where he says jay-z [ __ ] you
too
then it got [ __ ] up yeah
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
michael jones [ __ ] you too eric dubay
[ __ ] you too jordan peterson
that's right jordan peter
it starts off with [ __ ] him taking
shots at jordan peterson
that's what [ __ ] your daughter you
skinny [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah but they're gonna take the video
down vince vince is very litigious
besides y'all can suck on my big thing
y'all saying gravity is this
[ __ ] if this heavy is gonna just
like dropping a brick
so he thinks that the the sun should
fall because it's heavy that's correct
it's a very heavy but flat earthers also
don't believe in gravity
so what's the biggest slide you've ever
been told
would you like me to answer that frankie
no no no no
there's a whole youtube video about it
frank frank yeah i was saying we were
saying how hilarious we could turn
frankie frankie jq
because he seems like a guy that would
get hooked on anything well yeah
remember owen started with just the moon
thing
remember this whole story with owen just
saying guys i don't think we went to the
moon and
within a few months it was remember
harrison smith warned
when he came on our show he said do not
do not watch that documentary
and here we are today